blad Smiths welcome to the forge in this
first round of competition there will be
no signature blades in your signature
style I'm not even going to tell you
what the weapons tests
are instead I'm going to ask you to go
ahead and lift the cloths off your
anvils what you see on your Anvil is a
pristine piece of 1095 high carbon steel
that you will have to use to make one of
these
what is it I'm not going to tell you get
ready for a hell of a ride your 2 hours
Starts Now John's got the right idea
going sideways on big blue so stretch
that steel wide get that 3 in in big
blue has a fering dyes on one side
fullering dyes move the metal to the
side instead of forward so I can get the
width and the thickness I need for the
Finish
plate I am making a big wide crazy
spearhead of some sort that wouldn't
tell us the name but it looks
cool the biggest challenge is moving
this giant piece of Steel as a bit of a
purist I really like the idea of doing
100% hand hammered work but after seeing
how little it's going to move for me
under my sledgehammer I've realized that
my only option is to bring some power
tools into the equation all right so
nice to see that Chris has discovered
the power tool yeah Chris is already
tired I think all the
light I'm going to finish my foraging
and I'll start working on the rough
grinding my goal here today is to have
fun and winning is fun so I'm planning
to have a lot of
fun I like to design my weapons for
their intended purpose but not knowing
that I think it's really going to
motivate me to just make an allaround
badass weapon man that blade starting to
look really really nice and it's got
that right shape to
it one way I'm able to continue drying
out the steel towards the sides is by
using the hand Hammer to do my bevels so
I don't have as much grinding to do
meanwhile John running away with the
competition at this point I'm feeling
pretty good my blade is where I want it
to be but I got to add these notches to
the pointy blade thingy are we making a
spear today is this a spear is it a
hunting
implement
that's the fun part of this challenge we
know they don't know just make what you
see there I want to make sure I have the
same spacing as the piece that the
judges had I just don't want to go home
missing a parameter so I'm going to take
advantage of the sample weapon so I can
make mine as exact as I possibly can in
time I'm allow I am completely lost as
to what these notches are for but I'm
going and making them rounded so so that
I avoid any stress points in my blade
time for my heat treat I still think Ted
Ted blades on the thin side going for
the clench wait there we go all right
Ted just quench pull it out and it's
straight and I'm all happy with
that I feel really good about my spear
porn or whatever they want to call it I
got to get the heat treat done and I'll
be set I'm trying to stay one step ahead
of any problems that I see coming up
John's cutting out two pieces of angle
iron so he can clamp his playay it in
there after he
quenches and John just
quenched I'm pulling out everything
looks good but I know that it can warp
while it's finishing Harden so I throw
it into the jig just to make sure
everything's
perfect
textbook everything he does
yeah I don't have much time left I need
to
quench that chip red hot pressure is
just beating down on me at this point
but I'm going to get this blade
done beautiful this blade is hard I am
just a wash with joy and relief three 2
one blade SMI shut down your machines
drop your tools this first round of
competition is over
yeah all right gentlemen it's time for
the strength test I know you've been
waiting a while to find out what this
will be well the wait's over now to test
the strength and overall construction of
your weap weapons I will be throwing
them into our covered wagon over
here it's okay Chris it'll be fine now
this test isn't really about whether
your weapons stick into the Target or
not it's how they hold up that's
important all right Chris you're first
are you ready yes sir I am let's do
this my war club is going to be thrown
at a solid wall of wood planking I am
feeling scared to death right at this
moment
[Music]
[Applause]
la
all right Chris this thing is definitely
solid I'll tell you that much but
there's a lot of Mass to it the handle I
can just touch those fingers together
but as far as a strength test goes your
blade is still as sharp as when we
started it's still locked in and tight
it's strong held together good job Sir
John you're up next
okay I'm really nervous about this war
club I worried that the fit isn't tight
enough and the glue is not strong enough
the club could come apart the blade
could break there's just a number of
things that can go wrong at this
[Music]
point
all right John very solid you got some
good bling on there it's a good looking
piece but it's a little hard to range
this weapon in I mean that handle is
pretty pretty big having said that if
you got hit in the chest with this thing
that was flying at you whether the blade
hits you or not you're going
down still a perfectly effective weapon
whether I can get it ranged in or not
but as far as the strength test goes
everything's still right tight solid
good job he all right Ted you're up
ready for this let's do
it with my weapon I'm definitely
concerned about when it hits the wagon
something breaking
cracking man I can't watch that that's
horrific gentlemen before we began the
last round I told you that the
parameters were the absolute minimum
standard that your weapon had to meet to
even be looked at by the judges let
alone tested
Ted the back of the head of your war
club was supposed to fall between 7 and
9 in you are a/4 in short and therefore
your weapon cannot be tested and you
cannot be the forg and fire Champion
however we would like to commend your
performance here please Shake our hands
then shake your competitor's hands and
exit the
forge did great work my friend peaceful
I had no idea that I'd come up short on
the parameters good fight man keep your
head up thank you I should have double
checked
I got careless and that's what sending
me home this has been an amazing
experience and it's been an incredible
honor to be
[Music]
here